[Music]
so
[Music]
hello my name is cecil slipovic and i'm
musician in residence at yale
university's
fortune of video archive for holocaust
testimonies
this video series is designed as a
companion to our album
where is our homeland which is the first
volume in the archives ongoing effort
to present songs and poems performed by
survivors in testimonies given to the
fortune of archive
over the last 40 years you can learn
more about the project on the archives
website
songs from testimonies.org
where is our homeland songs from
testimonies volume 1
was recorded in 2019 by the cecil
slupovich ensemble
featuring renowned singer sasha luria
craig udelman on the violin joshua camp
on the accordion
keyboards and guitar dmitry ischenko on
the base
and myself on woodwinds the songs in
this collection differ vastly in terms
of style
social and historical background
language and many other aspects
but collectively they create a
multi-dimensional picture
of jewish life before and during world
war
ii fortune of video archive testimonies
hold a wide
variety of songs and poetry
the pre-war pieces alone formed quite a
large group
they include traditional songs of many
genres
military songs but honest the wedding
gestures cooplays and recitatives
zionist songs bundest songs communist
songs
really a wide variety of music and
poetry
jack m a native of the polish town of
schwarvetz
is remembering the songs that he heard
and remembered from the pre-war period
they're not only important because they
constitute a large
part of the ethnographic research of
polish jewry of polish culture of jewish
culture
but they also portray uh how the
people were really formed and shaped
uh before the war
and uh they help us understand
who those people really were as normal
human beings
not as just inmates as prisoners
at concentration camps and lay slave
labor camps
but human beings polish citizens
jews in his testimony jack
is remembering uh these
songs that he heard as he was serving in
the polish army
and those are quite interesting ones
uh the two songs that he remembered uh
were coming mostly from his commander in
his regiment
and one is quite openly anti-semitic
and the other one is rather frivolous
jack remembered them he did not consider
them
really negative but that
probably tells us about the degree of
tolerance
that the targeted group of population
groups societal group develops as a
survival tool
they were laughing at on us the
the christians anticipating all the
ground
in the the the made up a song
they took they took a jew to them
to the army in
in instead to give him
rose with bare
he gave him a cabbage soup they made up
a song like that
you remember the song yes in police
they took her to a
the gun should be loaded with ammunition
they put in the onion an onion in and
they asked him he should
he should shoot through his own wife
that was
too too late were there songs that you
knew in the army or sang in the army
from what
i said
yeah their song goes like that
about a guru
nevada soldier think that you
you understand
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a merry song here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm talking today about um
two songs which were recorded by an
amateur folk singer
a jack millstein a polish jew
he served in the polish army he was born
in 1913 so he served
in the polish army in the late uh
20s and early 30s
this was a difficult time i think for
jews in the polish army
the ncos the officers indeed the men
were not that sympathetic towards jewish
recruits
particularly ones who were not that
acculturated uh
milstein speaks sings his two songs
in polish i mean he has a slight accent
in polish but
his polish is clearly good and he has no
problems either
recording in polish or indeed presumably
speaking in polish
the first song is a song
so-called humorous song mocking jewish
recruits
instead of loading his gun with bullets
the jewish recruit loads his gun with
onions
because onions and jews like garlic and
jews is one of those
east european tropes not only does he
load his gun with
onions but he shoots at his wife
and his wife is called not kobeta but
kobita the woman
it's a rather lower class
a polish expression the other song he
sings
is a love song and it's a rather
attractive song
i mean i don't see it as being humorous
or in any sense
anti-jewish and what it reflects in my
view is the degree to which
polish popular culture had penetrated
into
the jewish world in the 1920s and the
1930s
although particularly after 1935
anti-semitism increased in poland and
indeed
in the early years of the pilsudski
regime after persuski to power in
may 1926 the government
attempted to reach an understanding with
the various national minorities
and indeed with the jews and until the
death of general pelsicki in may 1935
jews felt relatively comfortable but
throughout this period
in the period when the jewish situation
was relatively
good after 1926 and as it deteriorated
first under the impact of the great
depression and then after the death of
marshall kasich when a section of the
government camp
attempted to strengthen its position by
making
common cause with the anti-semitic part
of the polish right
there was a high degree of acculturation
taking place
so along with the deterioration of the
situation of the jews
they went in adoption of the polish
language and i think
this is reflected in milstein's
songs he sings songs in polish he has no
problem singing these songs in polish
and
he's clearly quite comfortable singing
them in polish
so they reflect on the one hand the
ambivalent position of the jews
relatively stable in the late 1920s and
early 1930s when milstein is serving in
the
polish army deteriorating after 1935
but also it reflects the growing
acculturation of jews
and one element in this which perhaps is
linked with these
songs is the fact that polish popular
culture
polish popular music polish songs
were an area where jews
were extremely active jews were among
the people who produced chairs
the vlasts and the other
major jewish singers these were people
who were
accepted on the larger polish scene and
as in the united states
the polish equivalent of tin pan alley
had a heavily
jewish component
[Music]
you